come and see what everyone's talking
about Jesus was his messenger this mail
out um diddle assalamu alaikum peace be
with you today in the studio we have
shared came out and mekhi we come back
here on the Dean show we are going to
answer some of the top five
misconceptions about Islam and then when
it clear out the junk from the trunk and
then we're going to deliver the sweet
message of Islam for all of those that
have been inspiring to know the truth
we're going to give you the clear simple
explanation of Islam we come back here
on the Dean sha Allah there's only one
but a new helmet is his messenger of
love
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice Salaam
alaikum peace be with you my lips Ilana
thank you very much my pleasure how you
been one hundred percent people can on
the Dean show calm they can visit you
have your own private special section
then click there on your picture and
they can view some of the other shows
that we've done with you I feel honored
I'm do the law to have my own section on
a Dean show that that's it fantastic but
the world know excellent we like to keep
it really simple very good so for the
not yet Muslims who are tuning in and
the Muslims who want to be able to
explain Islam but there are some Arabic
terms and some misconceptions associated
with some words so we're going to give
the people five of some of the common
basic misconceptions that people have
about some of these world you'll define
them explain them and at the end we'll
get rid of the junk out of the trunk and
then we'll go ahead and explain
everything in fools so they can
understand Islam a little bit better
sounds like let's start with this word
Allah okay people think that this is
some Arab God or this is a moon god and
they have this miss notion about this
word Allah so let's start with this word
Allah excellent very good you know the
the whole moon god and whatever other
claim they actually specifically the
moon god there's actually no evidence to
this whatsoever there's no record of
anyone God called Allah but
unfortunately it was people throughout
history who couldn't explain away Islam
and so they had the best thing they
could do is to forge some kind of lie
about it and said that allows some kind
of moon god in arabia and if that were
the case there would be a lot of
evidence to that it would be Arab poetry
talking about this moon god but we don't
have anything of that sort the name
Allah is very simply or the word Allah
is the name of God in Arabic and always
tell people if you go to any country
where there are Jews who speak Arabic
you will find them saying Allah you know
Morocco Yemen there's some Jews and they
say Allah and if you go to a church in
aerie any Muslim country or in the Arab
country and you'll see that the Arabic
Bible says Allah and those people say
Allah so sometimes you hear people say
things like you know Allah is not the
god of Moses so you're really and
Christians would say that so now what
would an Arab Christian say to this that
would be very offended by that because
they worship Allah and it's a known fact
that Muslims Christians and Jews they do
worship the same God they believe in the
same profits even the same geographic
locations or in both scriptures the next
common myth and misconception is that
people they have Islam synonymous with
terrorism right how would you go ahead
and explain this away well you know we
have a joke about that when we're in the
street talking to people and they ask us
this put on tell people to tell Muslims
to kill other people and we all would
tell him that well if that was the case
we wouldn't be talking right now you
know I know so actually there is a you
know terrorism is not part of Islam and
there isn't a verse that the command
tourism or anything of that sort but you
know the history of all religions not
just Islam is that there will always be
people who will either use religion to
support their cause or to support their
you know their their struggle and others
who will say you know we're doing it
because of this verse or that verse but
you have to consider the you know one
point three or more billion Muslims on
the planet if all of them were a part of
their religion was to go out and
terrorize it to kill people then there
would be a lot more havoc on earth but
then why is that we find only a small
handful of people who use the religions
name you know to commit terror or things
of that sort because there are people
who choose to you know interpret things
in a certain way and go in that
direction but if it was the general
mainstream then everybody would have
been doing it so there is no scripture
or part of scripture that says go and do
that so this is not and has nothing to
do with Islam like 911 this even Muslims
died a 911 exactly i mean and and nobody
you know nobody wants to consider that
so muslims died on in these buildings as
well so you know how could that be part
of islam to also if if you're claiming
Islam says kill non-muslims and
what Muslims get killed in this incident
as well and many other things like even
like even in Saudi Arabia itself they
had a number of terror acts where
civilians and Muslims got killed so that
means then we're dealing with specific
like rogue individuals who are
extremists or who have made
interpretations in such a way and they
use certain scripture to say this is how
we justify these actions so we've had
also i know i have it on the dean show
calm I've had other scholars on the show
they've condemned this and even when it
happened is it true that many of the top
scholars they didn't get much media
press but they all condemned hijacking
airplanes killing innocent women and
children 911 77 whatever times square
bomber all these things are not
according with the teachings of Islam
right it's not according to Islam and
the majority of scholars if not every
living scholar but still like you said
they don't get enough media attention
and what you hear is why don't the
Muslim scholars come out and and you
know and say this and that and they do
but nobody listens to them and at the
same time also it's very unfair where
you know a non-muslim would do the exact
same thing that a Muslim would do but
it's not referred to as terrorism and I
remember because I live in the
Washington DC area or I used to live and
we had a couple of years ago what was
known as the DC sniper and this guy
would go around and shoot people as
they're coming from work and leaving the
story things like that but he was
fantastic i was listening and he was
terrorizing everybody was afraid to get
gas during those days but I remember
clearly listening to the radio and they
say and the authorities have said that
the sniper is not repeat NOT a terrorist
what do you mean is not a terrorist is
terrorizing people yeah but what really
meant was that you know this is not a
Muslim so but he was terrorizing people
so he should be a terrorist by
definition so there's also a you know
it's not very fair when it comes to the
media the other day there was a guy this
is many years ago he packed his truck he
parked his tractor and the tractor it's
a farmer and he said he had enough the
amount of explosives that brought down
the oklahoma building and there was a
two-day standoff with him and the
newspapers only said
disgruntled farmer this guy had bombs
like the ones used in Oklahoma and he
only said disgruntled farmer I would
just love if that guy had a little bit
of a beard and he was you know Muslim it
would not say disgruntled the farmer
disgruntled it would immediately be a
terrorist whether there was a man who
actually flew a plane into the IRS
building and in Jacksonville Florida the
man blew up or try to blow up a mosque
and they didn't get much press nor were
they called terrorists no but if the
name was her son Riley he'd be a
terrorist this is wrong this is not
critical it's not fair we're people of
peace who call people to p's to acquire
peace by submitting to the owner piece
the one create tour excellent that's it
now let's take a break will be more back
with more of the common misconceptions
here on the Dean shop I am not afraid to
stand alone if a lot about this i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if a lot about the side I am
Not Afraid
I am not afraid to stand alone if a las
bombas I i am not afraid to stand alone
one god wish him alone do what he wants
you to do put your desires this thing
inside you that just wants this and
wants that and you just can't get enough
you know what you'll never get enough
until the dirts in your mouth don't let
it come to that be sincere and honest as
the one who created you to guide race
the first step put off chasing all the
women and the good times and the parties
and this and that there is no one would
be a voice ship except a lot don't wait
you never know is that would come today
for you
back here on the Dean show next one get
right into it we went from number 54 now
23 that Islam subjugates the woman
oppresses the women go ahead and take it
away what do we have to say well the
best thing we can say is ask Muslim
woman you see them in the streets all
over the place you know what they wear
asked them if they feel that they're
oppressed ask them if they're putting on
this garment because of their husband
because of pressure from the society or
they're doing it out of conviction that
they're doing is for their Lord and so
and if you look also in you know
Orthodox Jews the women cover the in
Christianity many different
denominations you'll find the woman
cover and the cover their head and tell
you something else and obviously when
you read the Bible it tells you that you
know the woman is not supposed to go
with her hair uncovered her head
uncovered in the church it clearly says
it's in the burger head off right well
there's 10 I don't think that happens
you know they still do this today that's
why if you're looking in the state
specifically always the woman will wear
a hat to church that had to church is
the remnant is the remainder of that
order to not go into church with your
head uncovered yeah so even the woman
wears her hat to church she doesn't
really know why she's doing it but she's
doing it initially because people used
to not uncover so now Jews they're not
supposed to uncover and the Christian
women are not supposed to uncover but
the ones following the scripture
primarily would be the Muslims and so
now they're singled out as the ones who
are you know whatever oppressed or this
and that but everybody's supposed to be
doing that to begin with wasn't the
church for some time contemplating if
the woman even had a soul yeah there
were all kinds of issues and if you
couldn't you know you would inherit the
women and all kinds of things and while
this was going on in Europe and other
places it's time had already given the
woman her rights and she was not a piece
of furniture and she was respected but
again it takes you know the honest
individual who is going to go out and
ask questions seeking the truth and
seeking the right answer and if you
examine and you can stop people and ask
them and speak to them and you'll see
the truth that it's not about oppression
or anything of that sort that the
Prophet Muhammad and they throw certain
false allegations on him that he
was a warlord that he was about war and
fighting and womanizing what we have to
say right if he was about world wars
wouldn't have stopped and he wouldn't
have signed peace treaties and he
wouldn't have you know refused to shed
blood and even when he was victorious
and conquered the city of Mecca
depressed Muslims for years when he gave
the standard to one of the soldiers that
soldier said today Allah will humiliate
the courage which is the tribe of Mecca
and today is the day of bloodshed so
what did he do he took the standard from
him and gave it actually to his son
place the son of saturn know about so
the truth is then if you wanted war you
know well keeps spilling blood but why
go through peace treaties why settle in
places and not go to war and why all
these things so if it was a warlord
wouldn't stop at anything just like you
know in history Napoleon for example you
know he didn't stop at anything he just
kept going and going and only the
weather would stop him he would come
back from Russia and then he would go to
Egypt and just kept killing you know so
that's one thing woman not as far as
bringing a womanizer you know the
womanizer doesn't get one or two or
three or four wives there's no limit you
know in the Quran there's a verse that
limits and tells the person that he
cannot take any wife after this right
and if he were a womanizer then he there
wouldn't be any limit and he would marry
as many as possible but his first wife
was 15 years older than him she was 40
and he was 25 and she was twice widowed
a womanizer doesn't marry someone like
that they may a young girl who's still a
virgin things like that he stayed with
her for 15 years now again a womanizer
wouldn't stay with one woman for that
long they just keep getting married
especially if you can pretend to be a
prophet and people think you're a
prophet of God you could put it right in
your Scripture tell people hey you want
to bless your wives bring them to the
Prophet we're going to brush your
daughter's bring him to the Prophet but
that wasn't the case and so when we
review and analyze the actions and no
marriages the process said lump we come
to a clear conclusion that he was not
doing it out of love of women and we
actually see other wisdoms behind his
marriages but again it's for the
truthful people to examine it unbiased
so we're making this short short and
sweet so you
can see that these things are just a lot
of childish accusations that are thrown
out some people are just going with the
flow and not really thinking but if any
thinking man or women come to this with
an open heart and open mind they can see
that a lot of these I just foolish
foolish things that really hold no
weight absolutely and if they were if
there was any truth to these things a
lot of Muslims wouldn't be Muslims but
the Muslims you know we examined them
and we know that it doesn't add up the
accusation doesn't add up and that's why
they don't hold much water Muslims they
say worship a black box in the desert
right and that the the black box is a
sacred house and it is not worship
whatsoever it is part of the ritual that
it's circumambulated seven times and
part of those rituals also have to deal
with submission because Islam means
submission and I to a man to a monkey
but submit to the One God who created
you and so part of submitting is we do
certain actions like for example when we
go around the sacred house which we
believe was built as early as a prophet
Adam and rebuilt again the Foundation's
by the Prophet Abraham or Ibrahim and
then so it had it's a sacred place and
has a great place in the hearts of the
believers and so part of the ritual is
to go and circumambulate the sacred
house now just like when you go to a
church you don't worship the church
building when you go to a mosque you
don't worship the mosque building when
you go to a synagogue you don't worship
the building but that's where you do the
worship and so when you go to Kaaba to
them temeka you do the worship in that
area in the quarter yard and around the
physical structure you're not
worshipping the structure and obviously
anything that's worship besides Allah is
greatly is shunned and discouraged and
prohibited towards of anything besides
Allah in Islam now tell us and go ahead
please because okay we move some of the
junk out of the way and now while many
other man-made religions they're very
difficult to understand the divine
religion the way of life system from the
crater has to be simple and has to fit
what's with what's deep inside
so show them just how simple it is when
you when you're able to just explain the
basic message of Islam and let's say two
minutes or three absolutely we can do it
in two minutes because it's so simple
and aloe would only revealed something
to you that you could understand and you
could fathom as a human being so it's
really simple and nothing is easier than
the number 14 isn't three isn't and
seven isn't one God who is indivisible
doesn't have children doesn't have
relatives or grandparents or partners or
neighbors or anything of that sort this
one God created all of humanity and out
of his fairness he communicates with
them the best way to talk to them is
through sending prophets and messengers
rather than appearing to them because if
he appears he has to appear for every
generation and for everyone that's being
born as we speak they need to see this
so the most the thing that makes the
most sense is that he sends prophets and
messengers these are good noble and
chosen people from amongst a nation or a
group and Allah will communicate with
them through the Archangel Gabriel and
this has been the situation if you read
throughout the Old Testament the New
Testament and the Quran this is our hola
communicate but he sent his final
prophet and messenger muhammad
sallallahu said lemon Arabia 1400 years
ago and he's not sending any profit
after him because he's going to preserve
his message so this is the easiest and
the most digestible thing for the human
being is that there's one God sends
Prophets sent all the great prophets
that we believe in as Muslims and he
sent the final messenger muhammad saw
said LEM and all of them came with the
same basic message so it's evidence they
came from the same school and that's it
simple suppose that and thank you we're
out of time my pleasure I got Almighty
Allah reward you once again for being
with us we look forward to having many
many more shows that lets her moncler
thank you any time and that's it that's
all we have we just wanted to give you a
taste move out to jump that's in the
trunk and deliver the clear message of
Islam continue to come back here every
week to the Dean show to get a free copy
of the translation of the Quran 1 866 to
Islam continue every week we're here
with a new show also check out our radio
show and we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be unto you is the lean-to
one of the beautiful things about our
religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer who God
directly there is no intermediary the
lights will go on after the party and
the party will end it's very simple and
very clear there are no superstitious
rituals no strange incantations the time
is running out we might not make it to
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about no speech is better
than to do that look all people to Allah
and to do there were no speeches better
no nothing is better than that is it
true that if one person I'm the Allah
giving you an ability to guide someone
for the lost permission the greatest
permission that was better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be getting out
getting done and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the mustards forget this
we want to print more we give these to
the Nautilus's for free for free for
free when our brothers age Eve's combed
ain't lay everybody sleeping I arise and
ask a lot of thinking me omar you see
all are you know all the sins i do i
turn to you to figure my sin to mom I'm
you see for slave you're my love alone
I'm the one runs away oh the guide me